welcome okay I came to something else p
PF lit coping ok I'm going with an
English opening let's see what we get
English is very transpositional yeah
like Ian fit get into a king's indian
I'm glad to transpose Kings in Eunice
opening that white should be well coming
not that it is terribly bad or anything
but it's the kind of opening that a
default player should enjoy to play your
gut central advantage some space all
those classical things and therefore
something that you should enjoy if you
play deform ok this is some line that is
well known i think but i have forgotten
the details i have to be totally honest
there i have looked at it once just very
briefly i have forgotten things it's a
this a 5c 5 line it's something where
black is some accepting to be a little
bit worse on the queenside for a long
time but he's pretty solid of course as
we see let's see Queen a7 i guess going
to play full scare proof plane to
invasion night a5 yes 496 the the big
difference of this line 22 other
classical lines is that black doesn't
really get those kind of big king-size
attacks very often he cannot even play
for them he tries though this player
tries
let's see how do I go about that I was
thinking knight c6 is kind of annoying
but maybe that's not not so true okay I
mean I've went to a five to put it there
so I should just do it yeah he I mean I
understand but what exactly is is he
doing here f3 just have three to bolster
things oh maybe Bishop d3 rook quick
Quincy seven look everyone who Kade this
is the the the big plan that I would
love to get in the moment is not
threatening to take maybe I should start
with that taking a look at CH d 7 and so
on I might have night a 7 by the way
night a 7
okay i don't have night before if i take
and 95 is this isn't this a simple
solution let's do that i take play 9 p-5
and then night a seventh this is isn't
this good 94 i think i can play a free
and I don't really know after night f7
night be to a seven how he keeps this
Bishop very elementary problem I'm
attacking c8 and where is he going
that's actually even after 94 as f3 f3 I
don't know does he have any kind of
stuff 92 some tricks if I go tonight b
28 7 how does he keep his bishop I don't
see how I don't see how might be six I
take
no that's that should really fall apart
completely 92 I play rugby one I mean I
could have played a three probably okay
counter-attacking near to d1 probably
just rarely save on
and yeah probably
what is he trying to do Bishop a6 giving
up d7 taking on c4 this is this kind of
thing I mean my nights are a little bit
on the edge but if they win material so
what
and on f3 you would have played 93 as
well of course okay so he's trying to do
Queen 32 may be okay
now that this is not really working come
on g2 cannot believe it one bit
Queen g6 or whatever I play g3 this is
ready I mean I have gotten check made it
quite often in the Kings Indian but it
looks fairly safe check check i also
have counter text now queen d 8 come on
let's do queen d 8 i'm what a map I'm
look up right check yeah also gets nice
to see 8 + d 8 which is really cute
resigns yeah that's a that's a nice
picture don't have that too often nights
on CA 10 d 8 by move 33 yeah as I said I
like this kind of line here it is not a
line that yeah this is this kind of
structure it is not a line that is
likable too likable likely to to to win
quickly on the queenside or anything but
it is kind of one-sided and black has
very little play this with King edge 898
Bishop h6 is something that can be
played in many Kings Indian lines the
drawback is it is very slow you get rid
of your Bishop your dark squared Bishop
but I see it took lots of time yeah King
age 898 Bishop age six and so on and in
the meantime I'm invading already on the
queenside and he has this like this some
liability on d6 he really has trouble
getting some kind of some kind of play
and here we are already here it's
already trouble my date seven maybe I
could have played night a seven right
away I wanted night b5 first it looked
it looks strong okay taking here first
is good anyway and now I went went I'd
be five I could have I could have played
night a 78
actually was thinking he has Queen D age
but this is this is this is totally
totally totally over really yeah he's
just dying out from his of his
weaknesses hmm ok the the issue with
this is it looks it looks strong because
I thought it it forces that kind of
cover and then I'm plane at sm anyway
but the engine says f4 and black is okay
with f3 coming yes man that's very
that's very true whatever I play a
defensive move check oh wow then this is
this is Major chats really made
checkmate and I'm made next move great
so I cannot play this f4 so what should
I play Bishop h5 is the computer
suggestion if I take here what is he
doing like there ma'am yeah this is this
is dangerous no question from trying
that yeah he's Andrew crooked coming
it's very dangerous I can what i can do
is i can do this and no here
check and draw that's a computer's best
line after that his nostril I am Bishop
a6 was still playable here here should
play Knight c8 actually winning here
bishop a6 what I suspected he would play
is in fact okay hmm cakes and the
computer says equal yeah playing this
position against the computer would have
been held up with other no it's not
equal look III is strong but who's who
finds that one ah amazing now this is
how it rented here man just winning
check I'm up everything yeah we saw it
it looked very one-sided but there were
some some some tricks there that he
could have gone for always always tricky
to play yeah thanks for watching